good morning believe nation today's
message is find your rhythm over to you
Marissa Mayer awake mode in espresso TV
go I've always had a philosophy around
balance a lobby we'll talk about balance
I don't really believe in balance but I
do believe in finding your rhythm and I
think a lot of it has to do not with
three square meals a day time at home at
night eight hours of sleep I think it
has to do with resentment because i
think what fuels burnout is this notion
of well wait i sacrificed this thing and
it honestly meant too much to me and it
made me resentful and for me it's really
about being able to walk out of the
office for one week every four to six
months find if I I start pushing that
out or delaying vacations I'll be like
you know I'm just not going to work that
hard tonight like I didn't get to take
that trip I really wanted to take so I
think you can work arbitrarily hard for
really long periods of time but you need
to know yourself well enough that you
can avoid resentment and avoid burnout I
love this message and I find that
balance is an interesting word I think a
lot of entrepreneurs try to separate a
home life and a work life and it's
really easy to have one blend into the
nether and the one thing that you
definitely do want to avoid is have a
resentment feeling like your business is
taking up so much of your time that you
can't spend time with your spouse and
with your kids and go on vacation and
the more and more you start to feel that
resentment the less you're going to
bring to your company right the more you
feel like your business is holding you
back the last successful you're going to
be and the less energy and motivation
you're going to have to do the great
things that you plan on doing and I find
that if that happens for too long then
something needs to change in your
business and I think one of the greatest
things of being an entrepreneur is you
get to set your schedule right the
reason why you left your job stop
working for the man to do your own thing
is you want to create a freedom you want
to be able to set your own hours you
want to create that schedule that
supports you and then somewhere along
the path
a lot of entrepreneurs we get locked
into a set schedule that maybe serve
this at the start but doesn't serve us
as well anymore and as we change and
grow as people we stop changing and
growing our schedule and then you end up
locked into this schedule that again
doesn't support you you have to realize
that as an entrepreneur you can change
it whenever you want because you're in
charge and so I find that this happens
with my schedule I would probably say at
least once a quarter you know I have set
days where I do set things I have a
morning routine but it's never fixed you
know the morning routine that I have is
not the same one that I had 10 years ago
while 13 years ago when I started this
business it's always changing based on
me and how I change and if it still
serves me or not and so what I encourage
you to do is if you find yourself
feeling resentful towards your business
and the work that you're doing then if
that's happening on an ongoing basis
something needs to change you need to
stop work with some of the clients are
you working with you need to stop
working with some of the people that
you're working with fire some of your
partners you know you need to change
your workout schedule your your work
schedule your morning routines your
habits everything and then I would sit
down and try to figure out the exercise
I go through is what are the big things
that I want to get accomplished what's
important for me in my personal life in
my business life what are the things
that need to happen that would make me
happy and then I plan those things in
put the big chunks in first and every
time I feel that my life is a little bit
out of balance I go back to my schedule
and make a change and that prevents you
from going off and getting you know
going off the deep end and being super
resentful and hateful and angry towards
your business because your business
should be something that fuels you that
motivates you that excites you allows
you to do great things that provides for
your family that helps you accomplish
your big goals not something that you
resent and you feel hold you back and
helping you get to where you want to go
so the question of the day today is how
do you find your rhythm and have you
ever felt resentful towards your
business leave in the comments below I'm
going to join in the discussion thank
you so much for watching have an amazing
they continue to believe and i'll see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot events presently expresso GV go